esta mañana la ciudad de abiyán parece
muy tranquila las calles permanecieron
vacías incluso por un domingo algunas
personas todavía van a la iglesia pero
son raras las pequeñas tiendas locales
permanecieron cerradas pero sabemos
también que muchos abiyaneses
abandonaron la ciudad antes de las
elecciones en las otras ciudades del
país las cosas también parecen muy
tranquilas el balance general permanece
sin cambios los observadores
internacionales de la sda de la unión
africana están desplegados por todo el
país para supervisar durante el día de
ayer se produjeron varios
enfrentamientos entre los manifestantes
y las fuerzas de seguridad en diferente
parte del país algunas ciudad como ya
museo y dau group fueron bloqueados a
ciertas horas del día según la policía
ayer hay al menos dos muertos la sala de
del día de hoy está muy ocupada con
conferencia de prensa